This is America's day.
This is democracy's day.
A day of history and hope, of renewal and resolve.
Through a crucible for the ages,...
...America has been tested anew and America has risen to the challenge.
Today, we celebrate the triumph not of a candidate...
...but of a cause, the cause of democracy.
The people, the will of the people, has been heard,...
...and the will of the people has been heeded.
We've learned again that democracy is precious,...
...democracy is fragile, and at this hour, my friends, democracy has prevailed.
On this hallowed ground where just a few days ago...
...violence sought to shake the Capitol's very foundation,...
...we come together as one nation under God, indivisible,...
...to carry out the peaceful transfer of power...
...as we have for more than two centuries.
As we look ahead in our uniquely American way, restless, bold, optimistic,...
...and set our sights on a nation we know we can be and we must be,...
...I thank my predecessors of both parties for their presence here today.
I thank them from the bottom of my heart.
And I know the resilience of our Constitution and the strength,...
...the strength of our nation.